let's go next where do we go next I
don't even know I'm thinking I'm
thinking we go to two four let's go to
the please don't I can't tell if it's
the two two four area code or country
code twenty-two but who is that yo can
you hear me
we can hear you yeah yeah oh hey David
it's Alex
I'm first kaga so I have a question for
you yeah for the future of the
Libertarian Party their economic message
is complete garbage do you think that if
they took a more centrist or progressive
approach with their economic message
while still keeping in touch with their
social libertarian policies but most
people seem so like do you think that
they could actually have a shot in the
future well then they'd kind of be
Democrats not libertarians right like
how give me an exist so let's imagine
imagine let's let's play that out
libertarians say we're gonna have our
social libertarian ideas which already
overlap with sort of the moderate left
give me an example of an economic policy
that they would change in order to have
broader appeal like that what would be
one example ah maybe like Medicare for
all but then you're not libertarian
right right because libertarians want
small government and they want less
government involvement they're not going
to say we're libertarians but we want
met that we want the biggest possible
government health program that we could
have which is the government provides
everybody's health insurance like it
then they wouldn't be libertarians
anymore you know what I mean sure sure
well I was referring it's more of like a
social libertarian message was more of a
centrist or almost progressive economic
message because a lot of the Democrats
don't really have a libertarian social
message if you catch my drift yeah I
mean I think it depends on the issue but
I think that the the problem is we're
you're focused on some really broad
labels and then you're saying what if
one label basically just changed so it
still had the label but it was something
else
that we consider Democrat like I just
don't I don't know it's it's a thought
experiment but I don't know how valuable
of one it is because it would basically
be the dissolution of libertarians as we
know them okay
yeah thank you all right well sorry I
can't say more about it appreciate the
call that is all the time we have for
today I know that there are many many
many people still holding and I
apologize we can't get to everybody
today but we will take calls again and
that will be a very exciting day and I
appreciate that everybody did call in
today